normalement je serai devant ma classe et
en ce moment je suis dans ma cuisine
noubol et puis je vais faire l'atelier
chez moi avec mes couteaux avec ma
planche
c'est mon thiam jean-françois qui
veulent filmer hockey excusé je
m'appelle gesca renault je suis chef
formatrice pour les brigades culinaire
pour la tablée des chefs
ici à sherbrooke dans le canton alès
bonjour kang
bienvenue à notre nouvelle capsule avant
la pandémie
non c'est sûr qu'on aurait jamais pu
imaginer qu'on allait tourner les
ateliers des brigades culinaire dans la
cuisine
les brigades culinaires sont présentes
dans l'eau dessus de 150 écoles partout
au québec jusqu'en une avic même et on
est présent dans une vingtaine d'écoles
à l'extérieur du québec également né le
22 août
c'est presque 4000 jeunes chaque année
qui sont rejoints par les ateliers
culinaires des brigades
aujourd'hui on veut tourner la dernière
capsule pour les brigades culinaire
c'est des ateliers qui normalement sont
animés par un chef formateur dans les
écoles le plus souvent parascolaires
donc évidemment pour son essai était mon
cul les écoles ont fermé à la tablée des
chefs on est assez débrouillard
je vous dirais on a sollicité par
exemple au chef formateur qui est
intéressé à le faire à produire des
capsules vidéo qu'on pourrait volleyer
via nos médias sociaux des capsules
vidéo avec des trucs des recettes pour
les jeunes pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à faire des apprentissages en
cuisine à la maison on a fait un premier
atelier jean françois et moi faisons une
capsule vidéo sur des types de coeur
globalement on a 130 quelques chefs qui
anime des ateliers partout au québec
là dessus il y en a une quinzaine qui
ont levé la main pour réaliser des
capsules vidéo ait eu plein plein de
choses des dessins des plots principaux
des choses un petit peu plus gastronomes
et et puis ensuite de l'as berck à bhl
nous a contactés ou qu'on filme des 3 2
ateliers qui auront pas eu lieu
donc le premier c'était un atelier sur
le poisson
le deuxième était sur la poutine donc on
est content parce que les jeunes avaient
hâte de faire cette recette là
évidemment donc pourront la faire la
maison
c'est l'occasion rêvée pour les parents
de laisser les jeunes prendre la place
qu'ils peuvent prendre dans la cuisine
parce que quand on les laisse là on les
encadre un peu rapidement autres agents
qui peuvent faire beaucoup de choses et
puis bon aujourd'hui dernière atelier
sur le gaspillage alimentaire qui est un
atelier très important le clip que
j'aime beaucoup
juste à ma course qu'il ya beaucoup de
gaspillage puis c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut éviter avec des trucs assez
simple savez vous que le tiers des
aliments qui sont cultivés finissent à
la poubelle et plein de recettes tout ce
qui existe
on utilise qu'on a au frigo il ramenait
les sourds des pâtes alimentaires les
salades de pâtes les sautés dernière
chose aussi que je voulais vous dire
l'organisation des ateliers à la maison
c'est assez particulier parce que il
faut penser à toutes les détails qu'on
n'est pas habitué qu'en cuisine à la
maison de jeux super notre bouffe tout
besoin peu plus mais là évidemment on
fait un grand ménage on met tout ce beau
on va aussi faire différentes prises de
vues des thèses de son l'autre sauter
asiatiques comme l'atelier aussi lieu en
anglais donc plusieurs reprises notre
qui sont faits notamment
on va faire une première comment est ce
que vous savez votre point les choses
n'étaient pas votre vin d'un très bon
pour moi parler devant une caméra comme
ça aussi c'est nouveau la question s'il
veut c'est triste parce que je m'ennuie
des jeunes j'aime beaucoup enseigné le
les jeunes adorent les ateliers sont
très impliqués mais c'est quand même un
projet qu'il phone affaires pas publics
et puis qui surgit comme ce dîner 1
d'une crise finalement très bon en fait
ça a été un groupe deuil de savoir que
je reverrai plus les jeunes parce que
les brigades finnair on est avec eux
pendant 24 ateliers et puis comme c'est
une activité en parascolaire les jeunes
sont l'oeuvre amant de leur plein gré
parce qu'ils aiment ce donc on développe
le vraiment entre moi j'ai développé
avec hull avec chaque groupe parce que
j'ai trois groupes une relation alors
aujourd'hui dernière ateliers ça me fait
plaisir de pouvoir les capsules pour eux
puis j'espère qu'ils vont le regarder
qui font de ces machines les capsules 7
phone dernière création de nous trois
capsules alors ça me fait le plaisir
d'être avec vous et on se revoit
l'automne prochain
tu en penses à bientôt
[Musique]